well the Las Vegas dad is finding
himself in a pretty tough position after
going to Great Lengths to provide a very
unique backyard for his daughter but
Victoria Saha joins us in studio tonight
to explain
Brian and Denise ever feel like your
intentions were right but the way you
went about it may have gotten you in
trouble well this is sort of what the
Edgar family is going through as you can
see behind me this massive Treehouse is
the center of their situation with the
homeowners association
okay twelve-year-old Claire loves
playing outside so her parents
transformed their backyard into a place
most kids would never want to leave you
could call it a tree house but that
doesn't really do it justice it really
is a piece of art a tree house where
Claire can be herself Claire has a a
little uh like learning disability so
she's a little bit of a loner and and
she spends a lot of time at home not
with her friends so uh it's good for her
to play in the garden the issue Philip
Edgar says is the board members of the
Las Vegas country club tell him they
don't approve it it is our fault that we
didn't uh follow the rules correctly up
front to get all the appropriate
permissions before we built it but it's
built and they want to keep it for
Claire man you like the tree house yeah
looking back would you be doing anything
differently
I would try to get all the appropriate
permissions beforehand absolutely that
might mean you could never even start
building it in the first place because
you wouldn't get those permissions Edgar
had tree Specialists come out and vouch
for him in their report they say this
feature needs to be preserved and
maintained as a benefit for the
homeowner and Community but Edgar says
the HOA is giving him two options
probably we're gonna have to either
completely take it down or at least put
it on the ground so that it's invisible
to the outs the outside world which
would make the Treehouse lose its
purpose and Claire would lose her Safe
Haven she loves it so it'll be a shame
I did reach out to the managers at the
Las Vegas country club Master
Association and which guidelines of this
treehouse didn't meet but I haven't
heard back from them we do also want to
mention the HOA would not let us on
their property